lui c'est mun
ce qu'il aime le plus c'est la liberté
mais tu peux pas tenir tranquille elle
ccir avec son père tue la liberté
elle connaît pas tu ne peux pas aller au
soleil et puis y'a sonne aujourd'hui il
va devenir le gardien du soleil gardien
mais pour mme une un événement va
changer son destin te voilà le nouveau
gardien de la lumière
quartier de la lune je crois qu'il ya eu
une méprise
ni lui l'a fait une terrible erreur en
choisissant cet imposteur brossoit
bouillant des diablotins volet soleil
et c'est toi qui devra gérer les
conséquences que je veux réparer ce que
j'ai provoqué c'est sérieux comme boulot
mini rongeurs je vous laisse continuer
votre concours d'ego on aime plaide a
sonné
je sais exactement où en vain